the operator of the company involved in
the deadly limousine crash that killed
20 people in New York State is free on
bail this morning Naumann Hussein
pleaded not guilty yesterday to a single
count of criminally negligent homicide
the 28 year old could face more charges
Tony copal is in Schoharie New York near
the site of the crash with new details
on the investigation Tony good morning
good morning since Saturday's crash
questions have swirled around prestige
limo it's safety record and it's illegal
licensing now the owner of the company
that's Nam and Hussein's father is out
of the country and has not been charged
with a crime but now that his son has
that means that while the federal NTSB
investigation into what happened will
continue state law enforcement has at
least begun to assign blame Naumann
Hussein left the Schoharie County
Courthouse last night after pleading not
guilty and posting a one hundred and
fifty thousand dollar bond
the sole responsibility for that motor
vehicle being on the road on Saturday
rest with nominee Hussein New York State
Police superintendent George Beach says
the 2001 Ford Excursion limousine that
was involved in Saturday's deadly crash
violated several safety standards that
vehicle was placed out of service by the
Department of Transportation in
September of this year and should not
have been on the road as recently as
September 4th a federal agency flagged
problems with the limos brakes this year
four of prestige limos vehicles were
cited for 22 maintenance violations
Hussein's attorney insists his client is
innocent my client
not guilty does not want sympathy or
pity from anybody he understands that
this is the process that has to take
place but certainly he was shaken by
what's happening the New York Department
of Transportation tells CBS News
prestige limo was warned not to operate
the vehicle the driver he hired should
not have been operating the type of
vehicle involved in Saturday's crash the
limo driver in the crash Scott listen
akia was reportedly stopped in August
for not having a proper license to drive
the limo
listen Nikki his widow told CBS this
morning her husband was a careful driver
he trusted and what the limo company
said that the cars were alright there
were a few times where he told me I'm
not going to drive this like this you
need to give me another car he cared
about who he drove now we want to
emphasize that investigators could bring
additional charges in this case
as for Naumann hussain this is not his
first tangle with the law in 2014 he was
convicted of attempting to switch
identities with his brother who had a
suspended license if he's convicted this
time of the charges so far he faces four
years behind bars John no need a couple
thank you Tony